how are EU laws made the European
Parliament is at the heart of EU law
making first the European commission
proposes a new law MEPS examine and
shape this proposal taking into account
your interests as voters their political
position and advice from experts this
work happens in their constituency
offices committees delegations political
groups and in negotiations with other
institutions MEPS EU governments and the
commission must then reach a consensus
before Parliament has its final say and
approves the new law remember Parliament
has a key role in shaping new EU laws
and throughout the process members will
represent you and your
[Music]
interests